foreign
welcome to a special episode of careful
boys we have with us today Mr Jesus
this question is kind of it's a
two-parter and it's mainly for Nick but
like what um hey Nick have you ever had
a homosexual experience and how many
times until you knew it wasn't for you
oh
how many times how many times
seven eight nah probably ten just don't
really know yeah they say like you have
to like when you're learning a language
my French teacher used to say this you
have to as he was French kissing you
yeah
Nick is playing as gay demons every time
he does Jiu Jitsu dude he's like yeah
have you ever had anything happen that
we kind of told the line no no honestly
honestly yeah yeah he's like right there
grabbing the guy oh [__]
[Music]
even Steve got a little bit of a grab
grab
a little grab
probably the the one thing that you
could consider okay yeah yeah he was the
best man he was the best man of my
wedding I love him to death we were at a
con and it was just as a joke and he was
like you know we're just kissing as a
joke yeah he confesses love to you at
the bar it's just like I I don't I
really like you dude I like you do I was
at a concert with my wife and he was
with some girl and then he was like he
won't kiss me I was like shut up [__] I
was like I'll kiss you right now if I
wanted you know and then and then I
kissed him right just a little Peck and
that was it and I was like yeah I didn't
like that at all
that's a power move yeah I was like I
was like what the [__] I was like I'm
comfortable with my sexuality to know
that I'll kiss you right in the lips and
then you know fantasize about it ever
since
dude I did that [__] to a comic he was
[__] get all mad he's just like I
don't like share rooms you know like so
I [__] kiss him because he's a
[__] gay guy dude
shut your [__] mouth dude with Daddy
now because of that [__] I don't like
that gay [__] negative energy in here
dude oh actually okay I gotta I got this
wasn't like gay or anything but it was
like we're in eighth grade and we did
like yeah yeah uh we were we had a we're
on an East Coast trip yeah and I roomed
with like these three Korean dudes I
didn't really know that well but they
were cool guys but we gotta share a bed
all three all four no no we have two
beds right we gotta share it bad and I
was like [__] it we'll sleep in the bed
and he started cuddling me in the middle
of the night like he's Korean Korean is
he crazy
and I was like yeah ever since that
night I couldn't sleep and [__] I was
like dude to cuddle no because like
they're they're lines of homosexuality
it's different it's very fluid Uncle uh
did your dick okay
[Laughter]
two man
I don't even
I don't even think that kid that started
cuddling me like even realizing he was
doing it like he was knocked out bro
like he was oh I think he was just like
okay he probably doesn't come but I just
was like this chick and I slept in the
bathtub ever since that I I in the
bathroom how did that happen you didn't
you didn't use a pillow partition we did
but he didn't get hard I don't think no
I don't think he's like when I thought
his dick into my legs I said that's it
dude
and you're like that's on my butt cheeks
but no we've I've never had anything
close to being like to be really
considered homosexual and you've never
like thought about it this is no way
this is the prop dude
what's going on I'm answering all like
seriously you know actually I think
that's something people wanted to know
they were just like foreign
all the fans were asking about Nick's
[__] homosexual experience he's a
good person to start I'll say this if
there's anyone here who might be me dude
yeah dude I'm honestly starting at this
time
I had a pretty gay experience and third
or I think third grade or second grade
uh I was at a pool party with my friend
and then like remember do you remember
like loving the piss with your friends
like when he's like I gotta pee and then
all of a sudden you're like I think I
got a P2 and everyone goes and you got
like four boys peeing in the same toilet
and you're all laughing yeah yeah so I
feel like crosses yeah it was that it
was that era right so then it was me and
my buddy Raymond so we're pissing in the
toilet right and we're just [__]
drenched from like being in the pool and
all we just have is like boxers on I
mean we're drenched in Europe [__]
swimming swimming shorts right and after
I and then we're done peeing he goes
sword fight and he goes over to me and
he just tries to [__] touch me with
his dick and I'm like no and then I
[__] went like this and then we're
like [__] going
like [__] crossing dicks and it was
the [__] weirdest but funniest thing
yeah because because he was like sword
fine and he just said because at first
you're like get away from me I don't
want to touch your dick but it's a sword
fight so if he's going yeah you never
back down for a fight yeah dude yeah
he's like
a sword too you know and then you go and
then you're just [__] like unsheet
dude you're just [__] no it's more
like this and just go like [__] oh [__]
and then you're just like going slow
motion you're like [__] like making
lightsaber noises I'm a cover your sword
we started [__] crying laughing so
hard because it was the funniest [__]
right it's like you're just and then we
just I mean we went back and just played
in the pool but like anything super kid
I it's hard to call homosexual when
you're talking about
just being kids yeah but it's like I'll
give you this but you don't know that
it's gay but it's like what is it it's
kind of like experimenting with your
body which which is not necessarily gay
it's it's just kids yeah you know what I
mean you're just playing okay so it's
pretty dick to dick though pretty bare
so is this game I remember I was playing
it's this game okay I'm gonna throw this
out there dude I feel like we're all
sharing he's like so last week
like I don't know I think it was eighth
grade but you know you're starting
getting into puberty you know what I
mean and that was the talk in the
basketball court it was like oh yeah I
got here I got pubic in like you know
how [__] yo dude
[Applause]
I had a homie that just [__] just
straight like yeah dude [__] he's he
didn't just show he just the thing just
flopped out and we were all like oh my
God like
I was I was tying my shoes oh my god
dude we were like how do you have a man
dick already like we all had like this
like what he was doing yeah because he
just look at it I remember just the way
it flopped I remember going like that's
a weight
I'm just like oh my God we were all just
kind of like yeah like in the shoes to
tie no I'm talking so science yeah no no
that's the thing though we were all kind
of like broke wow how old were you guys
he was just like dude it's [__] and
we're like was he like I don't have hair
yet
massive [__]
eighth grade yeah eighth grade he just
had a man dick he had a hanger yeah and
dude after that like he would like be
cocky about it like in the P room he
would just be out there like just
freaking we're like all right all right
put it away we don't want to see your
dick dude you wanna see your [__] cat
dude makes me feel insecure but when we
had a girl so he had a girlfriend and we
were all just like poor girl
like we all knew and then you know
because we we've you know we've seen
this we were just like oh poor [__]
girl dude
lucky girl
oh so we're gonna get true true okay
okay yeah I got kissed by a guy at a
club in Australia oh yeah oh yeah it was
during the tick tick tour and then the
what so we did a tour the dick dick tour
Bart let me say something right now dude
if you told me that you were going to
some thing called a dick dick tour
and you start complaining about some guy
kissing you it's your own fault my guy
you had it coming we're going to The Dig
Tour all right once you say you want to
go to a dick I stop over right there and
be like don't you start bringing
yourself monster regular at the dick
dick too though yeah people know him
they call him Big B over there it's Big
B
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
do you guys sometimes feel like you
stink because we all been there okay
it's a hot humid summer day and Summer's
right around the corner and you're
sitting very close in your class to the
girl of your dreams or you're just in
the bus and you're like what is that did
somebody fart and you realize no it's
not a fart it's you and you're like how
did this even happen and you're so
disgusted with yourself and you're like
but you know I did forget to take a
shower duh and you wish that you had a
solution well this is why Lumi is kind
of cool it's because it's a whole body
deodorant some people just do it here
but if you're like me you want to go
here you want to go here you want to go
in your in between your man boobs you
want to go in your neck you want to go
behind your ears you want to go
everywhere it's a whole body deodorant
for the whole body experience just in
case you skipped a shower or something
and it's designed by OB GYN for the
downstairs and that's why it works
everywhere because if you're like me and
you're a man of experimentation you
actually tried regular deodorant yeah
and you put it here and then you're like
I want my dick to smell like that too
yeah you put on a dick and starts
burning like a [__] yep it's
because it's different this [__] you got
you don't got the aluminums no
eucalyptus oil to burn your dick like
it's made out of some kind of uh Menthol
fire yeah like you don't got no parabens
nope it's it's it's safe enough for your
private so you can put it anywhere so
your whole body can smell nice and clean
and here's a little hint get the fresh
Alpine yep and ladies it's ph balanced
so it's safe to use below the belt yeah
but don't put it inside no one does it
like that that's dangerous if you're
horny use something else yep uh there's
tools for that but just yeah be careful
Lumi starter pack is super perfect for
new customers it comes with a solid
Stick deodorant cream tube deodorant two
free products of your choice like mini
body wash and deodorant White and on top
of that free shipping as a special offer
for our listeners that's you new
customers get five dollars off a Lumi
starter pack with code OTR Lumi
deodorant.com that equates over 40 okay
of your starter pack when you visit Lumi
deodorant.com and use the code OTR we
were at a club because I think after
every show we went to a club after yeah
and then we went to a club or just like
dancing hanging out whatever and then
this guy comes up to me he goes hey like
I'm a big fan of JK I'm oh cool thank
you so much and then like you know when
you like do like the Bro hug thing and
he comes in and kisses me like on the
ear and I was like oh [__] what the [__]
and then I was just like they just
caught me off guard please
this is on the ears
yeah he probably got nervous he just
gave you a take care
hey call me when you get home yeah
be safe out here there's a lot of ways
there's a lot of ways you can kiss the
homie there's a lot of ways you can kiss
your homies
wait how did you react my foot went numb
you know that's my spot chills down my
spine you know hardly all that things
hahaha
it'll do that dog
I can't stop there's my [__] love
pocket
no I just caught me off you know
sometimes when something happens you're
just like
unkiss him yeah yeah dude that's like a
hard dude I wish I got kissed I
that [__] crazy dude didn't you have
something you wanted to say well yeah
share dude which story do you guys want
is going on
dudes throw themselves at you I know you
do come on just be honest I got I got I
got two little stories I guess let's go
in the dance no it's not that crazy no I
will say when I was young I was like
um a really stupid boy right uh not kid
but like you know uh in like later half
of high school later half High School I
remember you know just being like with
summer camp people type stuff right and
um man I was I was that dude who was
like so [__] horny that like when you
know when at summer camp when you're
playing like Truth or Dare type stuff
you know you're like like looking at all
the girls and you're trying you're
trying to [__] decipher who's [__]
down you know and you're like oh I dare
I dare this chick to make out this chick
you know what I mean and then I started
getting good like people would listen to
me I was like charismatic in that like
[__] horny ass like little kid way I
was very extrovert with that but then
finally when the tables got turned and
somebody pointed it out I mean they're
like you gotta kiss that guy oh [__] and
it was that's when the double standard
turns around I'm like off [__] I didn't
think that I would get called out
because you know you're just thinking
like yeah girls are down girls are down
right but when it [__] throw gets
called out on you and everybody's like
yeah yeah and you're like
so there was definitely a moment and you
know everybody had to make rules about
it too they're like you can't be quick
it's gonna be at least with seven
seconds a long time me and this [__]
dude he's easy you did it you did it
just standing there like
just [__] making calls like the
smallest one oh yeah yeah
um
you know what I mean but like he got
pushed back he's like
[Laughter]
he's just like
yeah Second Story that was crazy oh so
it was not as fun but funny I guess but
um yeah so um
when you're like spot and you made other
people do it and you're just like dude
you have to do it you gotta do it
because I just felt like that one is so
waxy like no
no you know what I mean so stupid
let's go like man Anthony [__] him B
yeah if you didn't do a dude you would
be gay
and then
uh it was super duper you know this
dancer but uh you know dancer
sometimes you go on [__] trips and
you know you're like teaching at
workshops and stuff over overseas and
whatnot and you know same thing like you
know you're getting drunk and stuff and
dude first of all if you that sentence
alone dude is enough
you're sorry cool you're this dancer one
thing listen to another you take a trip
you know are you guys drunk and I'm like
bro this is going super game already
go on dude who else is going to share
because I would have said no
first thing you know this dancer no I
don't know you know you take guys trips
nope don't do that either
right no go for it you know what all the
guys are naked no I wouldn't do that
um but but you know uh in the especially
again in the dance Community there there
is a totally different you know level of
normal comfort with stuff like that and
there's a lot of gay people in that
scene so you're very very comfortable
with them you build relationships with a
lot of different people
um and then sometimes those gay homies
they they try to have fun with you they
poke at you you know what I'm saying
they like you sure you're not gay like
that you know yeah you sure you don't
like that [__] oh they have fun with it
um and then you know sometimes when you
you are drunk and when you're like you
know you've been through it enough and
you're comfortable sometimes you're like
you wanna [__] [__] around let's [__]
on but you're not down to [__] around
you're just like saying it yeah
you start egging them on even though you
know you're not gonna do anything hey
dude start slapping your ass once or
twice and they're just like [__] like
all right all right dude it's all right
just one slap and that's it all right
hey dude hey dude
it goes so much in the same thing you
don't want to be in that position where
you're like fighting something off in a
way that makes it like weird yeah yeah
you know what I mean so yeah you're like
fine [__] it you know what I mean you
wanna you wanna be okay like oh I'll
[__] be gay but you're not gonna do
anything yeah yeah but then if more
alcohol gets consumed later on and
you're still in that same spot like I'm
not gonna do anything but then now
they've gone farther than you thought
they they're like all right dude that's
getting uncomfortable a little bit now
they're fishing yeah you know what I
mean now it's getting a little it's
getting more it's getting touchy in ways
that are like you know I was like wait
this isn't so I feel like those those
moments have happened but uh other than
that you know it's just you chalk it up
to being like Hey look it's cool like
we're grown people so yeah I'm not going
to make it a thing you play with fire
yeah you do play on fire because they're
they're [__] you know it's they're
they're [__] waiting they're fighting
you play with fire
you will get burned
up yeah you Dance with the Devil this
will happen you Tango with El Diablo
yeah this is what happens but I think
that's I think that's what you got to be
careful is all you know what's once like
alcohol and stuff like that comes in
there and people are like inebriated
then they get hard to get blurred and
then it's like
when the heart starts pumping dude but I
still go home and I'm like yo that was
weird and then I look in the mirror and
I'm like I still got it yeah
yeah baby you're gonna talk about
it
give us another game story Joe no that's
the thing though it starts like that but
then listen you start drinking start
doing the arm [__] thing you want to
[__] arm wrestling and yeah
[Laughter]
I'm doing it I'm gonna fight your hands
oh don't [__] stop
this [__] guy knows what's up dude
playing with pirate baby we're driving
and it's like everybody's asleep we're
doing a road trip and the gay comic and
I'm just telling them like what's what
are you guys be doing over there you and
your [__] friends are like no it's
[__] it's like and I'm like oh yeah
that's crazy so you know he's like you
ever had like a head from like a gay guy
and I'm like no why would I do that it's
like just the best I was like that it
probably is the best well they're not
lying that's the thing it's true at
first I was like dude of course you know
girl would be better is like a guy knows
how you like it but the way he's saying
it it's three in the morning it's quiet
the stars are out yeah in a Ford Taurus
all of a sudden [__] Spotify starts
playing [__] Sam Smith and I'm like
oh oh what's happening here dude you
know and he's just convincing the idea
of like I know how you like it it does
and I'm like what are you talking about
this is his hand yeah I'm just like what
he's like dude I know I know the spot
let me pull I'm a guy I know what you
like
what what do you mean gripping the
stairs no the spots I know where you
like it I'm a guy I know this you know
girls don't know they just go but I know
how to like go slow and I'm like oh
I was like what what do you mean dude
I'll just let me show oh
[Music]
no but I was like whoa that's pretty
crazy but then I was like nah just come
on [__] never dude
sweating the whole trip like you're
[__] wow dude I just tried on my
finger then let me see yeah yeah I
imagine driving
oh you're like damn you're really good
all the comics blinking I'm just like
dude what the [__] just happened what
you told me
this guy's good huh he knows what he's
doing I'm not gonna ride with Reggie on
the way back dude
yo that was [__] funny dude oh well
done